[Music]
what is it
he knows my settlements
dear God it has wings it's coming
please
check
what's wrong I heard you knock
minor
[Music]
foreign
you think above all else you feed
you awesome
to seeing you underneath your phrase
you're afraid of what lies on the other
side and any other living things
it is spoken in my Village
of an evil
that lives in the mountains above
an evil that appears as a man when it
wants to hide its true nature and that
night he feeds on the blood of the
innocent the elders they made bargains
to you about people
you were given to this man this
is an animal no it is not some
mindless animal either do not make that
mistake
we call him Dracula and you you believe
that
he brought you on board
[Music]
he brought me here to feed
he is here Mr Clements
the thing that wears the skin of a man
[Music]
in the night it rings our blood that he
is on this ship
is that we will never leave it
we have a plan if we you've seen what
they've seen then you still want to plan
they say Cambridge astronomer you can't
think your way out of this one
this piece
and mark my words it is a beast
deep down I need it to make sense too I
need to know why it is the way it is why
it does what it does and then I will
remind the Beast that it like the world
has absolutely no hold over me
I warned you
I warned all you didn't I
it is a punishment brought down for our
sins petrovsky a criminal olgar and
Gypsy hidden a whoremonger a lecture and
from Gomorrah herself oh you shut the
hell up you bleeding idiot
Abrams
take the morning watch
relief it will be the next to Rise Up
from death
Satan's black blood pumping corruption
through his veins God's anger has come
upon this vessel like donuts
what a doomed crew Mr Columbus
on a doomedship
we no longer plot our course
the devil below death
and we all know where he plans to
deliver us
to Hell Mr Clements
I wanted this to be the scariest
depiction of Dracula ever there's
something potent about that mythology
everyone knows fear and I think Dracula
represents that this chapter of Bram
Stoker's Dracula hasn't been told
what actually happened on the ship that
transported Dracula from the port of
Varna to England
is by itself just fascinating
Dracula is trying to find more people
more blood a better place to feed this
looks like a bite what better place than
the huge Brazilian of London search the
ship everywhere
it's monster time when the lights go ill
I really loved this alien style story
set on the ocean in 1897 and with
Dracula instead of the alien monster it
was just all the elements were really
exciting
there's no way off this ship and that
evil is lurking right there we've yet to
experience this extreme emotion of fear
but safely
may God have mercy on us all he's the
perfect monster you look at the images
and it's just magic man it's magic
it's Dracula and I want to kill the
cusset thing
the Demeter
on Charter from Romanian to London
shipping private crates
content unknown
out at Sea with no land in sight
we dress like a learned man University
of Cambridge and on my way around the
boat our Charter has agreed to pay a
bonus for timely arrival number
let me show you the ship this
we don't come with like this to give the
oils clear
[Applause]
something ripped about the animals
all the livestock this looks like a bite
search the ship everywhere
evil isn't bored
powerful evil
[Music]
change I'm still just friends
in night it drinks our blood he is here
we call him Dracula
he's coming
see the size of that Bloody things
[Music]
he is on this ship which means that we
will never leave
the devil is real
may God have mercy on us all
[Music]